so you see that the BMOC which the B
stands for one-time marker em another Oh
another yes 30 pay 30 60 90 110 pay okay
in a script movie script so to play the
devil's advocate here we sometimes see
these comments usually they come in late
at night which are this is why Hollywood
writes formulaic crap yes how do we how
do we contend that how do we say well
then maybe Hollywood's not for you what
what would be your aunt someone take a
show that I think the new Robert Altman
is a guy named Glover he's a guy that
wrote his writing a short now called
Atlanta now Atlanta is I think the
hippest half-hour show on television
it's a Glover's an african-american dude
he's been an actor in several big shows
and but now he's got his own show this
guy gives us a world that we've never
seen before which is the world of middle
and lower middle-class african-american
Atlanta okay now Atlanta is a cool city
and it's a big there's a big
african-american culture that's part of
it lanta I would submit to you you
probably don't know much about that
world right I totally didn't right he
shows you and that's one of the great
things there's nine questions I ask you
when you when I'm working with you on
the television show one of them is you
showing me a world I ain't seen before
because I don't want to see New York
again on the Upper East Side
please right show me a new world right
so this is the world of middle and lower
middle class Atlanta and it's very so
Africa in American Atlanta and it's very
specific and the story feels very loose
if you go look at the pilot of Atlanta
and it doesn't look like it's about much
sort of like a Robert Altman movie it's
got a very loose feel to it it feels
very improvisational it feels like
there's no rules at all right and this
story it's got every rule every
structure every story line ever
rhythm of How I Met Your Mother or the
most commercial sitcom II structure that
you've ever won or ever not want or if a
you're a hipster you'd say I don't want
to write that right it follows all the
rules so why is it so cool because it
takes those rules and it shows you stuff
you've never seen the reason people say
uh Hollywood so formulaic is they're
looking at bad unimaginative stories
with characters you've seen a thousand
times with situations you've been in a
thousand times with care with within a
world you've seen a thousand times set
but the structure the commercial
structure is there because it's
beautiful the bones are beautiful you
can take different bones out put other
bones in but there's an appeal below the
surface of beauty if you look at what we
consider to be beauty if you took a
skeleton you'd see there was a
conformity to the bone structure now you
can put whatever you want on top of that
bone structure you can make the person a
Tunisian you can make them Indian you
can make them American Indian you can
make them whatever you want but the
bones below that determines whether or
not they're beautiful I think structure
of story is like the bones beneath the
the the face it's what we're
instinctively drawn to as human beings
and that doesn't change but what changes
what makes things unique are is it a new
world are these characters we haven't
seen before is this guy have a wound
that we haven't seen before a Glover in
Atlanta gives us a guy who is a real
smart guy who went to Princeton but he
failed because he's got a car loan that
he's a loser
and he's come back and he's just bumping
around and hanging out in this middle
class lower middle class world of
African America Atlanta
he's a loser he left Princeton probably
because he felt like I own these people
aren't like me which I felt whenever I
went to an Ivy League school I felt the
same thing
so I because I'm a loser I'm gonna drop
out and I'm gonna go back home now back
in Atlanta he gets involved with his
cousin who's a hip-hop artist who he
shouldn't get involved with he also
already has a baby
Glover does his character does and he's
not being a really good father but he's
trying he's not being a good husband at
all so all the things all the elements
that we've seen from a dozen sitcoms
from 1960 on are all present in Atlanta
but because we've never seen this world
before because we've never seen this
so he's is kind of a slacker an
african-american slacker and it's also
very funny so every commercial cliche of
structures in this story and yet it's
the freshest thing on television and so
that's my argument against not using
structure think of it this way in
California we have these these a vanity
license plates right and and in a vanity
license plate I think you get seven
letters right and in that seven letters
you've got to be witty okay you can't go
oh man you know what it's such a cliche
to have seven letters my vanity place is
gonna have 42 because if you take if you
make the vanity wait 42 characters long
it's not going to be funny when you say
you know if you have a seven letter word
that says let's say you're driving a
Corvette and your seven letters are two
inches right okay that's how ya got mean
a lot if it was a 42 letter play you go
hey
I Drive a vet because I have a small
penis is that funny no because if the
forum is too big so commercial forum is
what we delight and we want the
limitations of commercial forum produce
the the entertainment right the fact
it's a half an hour means you must cram
certain things in it and the delight of
an audience
and the commercial art form is how are
they gonna cram something we've never
heard about and is witty into this
limited commercial form that's what
commercial art does that's why it's
commercial art you want to make a sitcom
that doesn't follow the rules great make
one that's four hours long don't follow
any of the rules you can do it but it's
not commercial art and your audience
will probably be fairly limited unless
you're such a super genius you're gonna
create an entire new art form what's
what Susie's gonna do she's look you can
make an entire new art form please God
let's see it from you I'd love to see it
but you're gonna have to be greater than
Shakespeare who by the way used a 3x
truck sure okay
Shakespeare worked inside a commercial
structure the structure of
stratford-on-avon
he worked inside that structure his
plays were inside a commercial structure
and yet they're the greatest place in
history so you can be original and be
commercial - that's my seductive message
for for the Hollywood that there
is a Hollywood pimp telling you come on
baby get in the Sirah glio do it our way
you can still be original
[Laughter]
you